Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. It is said that Scipio Aemilianus, as Carthage was going up in flames, its annihilation almost complete, gazed at the city in its death throes and openly wept for his enemies. He stood, wrapped in thought for a long time, pondering how every city, every people, every empire, must, as men do, meet with their doom in the end. For such had been the fate of Troy, once a proud and flourishing city, and of the empires of Assyria, Media and Persia, each in their own day the greatest in the world,
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。据说，当迦太基城陷入火海，几乎被彻底毁灭时，大西庇阿（Scipio Aemilianus）凝视着这座垂死的城市，为他的敌人公开落泪。他伫立良久，陷入沉思，感叹每一座城市、每一个民族、每一个帝国，终究都难逃像人类一样的宿命。因为特洛伊曾是一座引以为傲、繁荣昌盛的城市，亚述、米底和波斯帝国也曾各领风骚，在各自的时代称霸世界，
and of Macedon, which only recently had blazed with such a brilliance. And then, either deliberately or because he could not help quoting them, Scipio spoke two lines of Homer. A day will come when sacred Troy shall perish, and Priam and his people all be slain. And when Polybius, speaking to him with the freedom he was granted as Scipio's tutor, asked him what he meant by these words, it is said that without any attempt to veil his meaning, Scipio made reference to his own country. For when he pondered how all things that are mortal must fall he dreaded how Rome too would fall so that's the end of the story of Carthage the destruction of Carthage and the great Roman
还有不久前曾光芒万丈的马其顿。随后，或许是出于刻意，又或许是情不自禁地引用，西庇阿念出了荷马的两行诗句：“神圣的特洛伊终将毁灭，普里阿摩斯及其子民终将丧命。”当波利比乌斯（Polybius）以西庇阿导师的身份直言不讳地询问他为何说出这些话时，据说西庇阿毫不掩饰地提到了自己的祖国。因为当他思考万物终将消亡时，他也恐惧罗马终有一天会走向灭亡。这就是迦太基故事的结局，迦太基的毁灭，以及伟大的罗马
general Scipio looks out and he mourns not just the fate of Carthage and of all empires but he thinks about the fate that awaits Rome itself. And so, Tom, we're doing this mighty series about Carthage. We're looking forward here to the end of the story. And that's an absolutely fascinating passage because that implies a degree of empathy for Rome's great enemies that we wouldn't normally associate with the Romans. Which we have to say is very unusual. So the Polybius who is mentioned in that passage is really our great source for much of the story we're going to be telling. So he was a Greek who had been taken hostage and taken to Rome in the second century BC.
将军西庇阿眺望远方，他哀悼的不仅是迦太基和所有帝国的命运，更是在思考等待着罗马本身的命运。所以，汤姆，我们正在制作这个关于迦太基的宏大系列。我们在这里展望故事的终局。那段文字非常引人入胜，因为它暗示了对罗马宿敌的一种同情，这在通常的罗马人身上是看不到的。我们必须说，这非常罕见。文中提到的波利比乌斯，确实是我们讲述大部分故事的重要来源。他是一位希腊人，在公元前二世纪被当作人质带到了罗马。
And he wrote a history about how what had been a multipolar world, so a Mediterranean full of different states, had become a unipolar world ruled so a Mediterranean full of different states, had become a unipolar world ruled by Rome. And this was his great theme. And the destruction of Carthage is the climax of his story. And the fact that the city is obliterated and that the Romans hated it so much that they were willing to inflict this terrible fate on what had been one of the great, great cities of the Mediterranean, kind of points to what is kind of glamorous, mysterious, and cruel about Carthage's reputation. Because the fact that most of what we know about Carthage comes from its enemies gives it a slightly kind of malevolent aura in the sources that we have. So it's a bit like the city equivalent of Cleopatra, right? All we know about Cleopatra
他撰写了一部历史，讲述了曾经多极化的世界——即充满不同国家的地中海——是如何变成了一个由罗马统治的单极世界。这就是他的宏大主题。迦太基的毁灭是他故事的高潮。这座城市被抹去，罗马人对它恨之入骨，以至于愿意对这座曾经地中海最伟大的城市之一施加如此可怕的命运，这在某种程度上指出了迦太基名声中那种迷人、神秘而又残酷的特质。因为我们对迦太基的大部分了解都来自它的敌人，这使得我们在现有的史料中，它带有一种略显邪恶的光环。所以，它有点像城市版的克利奥帕特拉（埃及艳后），对吧？我们对克利奥帕特拉的了解
generally comes from her enemies. And the same is true of Carthage too. They're both seen as really glamorous, sinister, depraved, degenerate, luxurious, all of those kind of orientalist things. Is that fair? Yeah. And we've talked about how Dido, the legendary founder of Carthage, in Virgil's great poem, The Aeneid, she is equated with Cleopatra. So that sense of kind of simultaneous, the glamour and the cruelty is absolutely enhanced by the fact that, I mean, the Romans really hated Carthage. Carthage is the city that pushes Rome closer to destruction than any other enemy that she has to face. And of course, I mean, even Scipio in that passage, he's not really weeping for Carthage. As you say, he's weeping for Rome. And throughout the Roman sources, the Latin word
通常都来自她的敌人。迦太基也是如此。它们都被视为极其迷人、阴险、堕落、颓废、奢华，带有所有那种东方主义的色彩。这样说公平吗？是的。我们之前谈到过，维吉尔的伟大史诗《埃涅阿斯纪》中迦太基的传奇奠基人狄多（Dido），她就被比作克利奥帕特拉。那种迷人与残酷并存的感觉，因为罗马人确实非常痛恨迦太基而得到了绝对的加强。迦太基是那个让罗马比面对任何其他敌人时都更接近毁灭的城市。当然，即使是西庇阿在那段文字中，他也不是真的在为迦太基哭泣。正如你所说，他是在为罗马哭泣。在整个罗马史料中，拉丁语中
for Carthaginian, punicus, I mean, it's almost always used as a kind of term of abuse. It's always associated with negative connotations. And even if you look at the Greeks, when they write about Carthage, because the Greeks had been rivals with the Carthaginians for centuries and centuries, kind of trade rivals, and particularly in Sicily, they'd been geopolitical rivals. I mean, they hate the Carthaginians too. So Polybius begins his history with the first great war between the Romans and the Carthaginians too. So Polybius begins his history with the first great war between the Romans and the Carthaginians, what we call the first Punic war. But there had been a history that had ended at that point written by a guy called Timaeus. And Timaeus hated the Carthaginians.
表示“迦太基人”的词“punicus”，几乎总是被用作一种辱骂性的词汇。它总是与负面含义联系在一起。即使你看希腊人，当他们写到迦太基时，因为希腊人与迦太基人进行了几个世纪的贸易竞争，特别是在西西里岛，他们是地缘政治上的竞争对手。他们也痛恨迦太基人。所以波利比乌斯以罗马人和迦太基人之间的第一次大战开始了他的历史，也就是我们所说的第一次布匿战争。但在那之前，有一个叫提迈奥斯（Timaeus）的人写过一段历史，而提迈奥斯痛恨迦太基人。
Everything he writes about them is kind of negative. And so he liked the Romans. It's endlessly going on about how the Carthaginians are treacherous. They're cruel. So Timaeus, I mean, he can't get enough about child sacrifice. He absolutely loves that. He's always going on about it. And perhaps the most shocking thing that Timaeus alleges about the Carthaginians is that they wear underpants beneath their robes. They wear underpants underneath their robes. Yeah.
他写的一切关于他们的东西都是负面的。他喜欢罗马人。他喋喋不休地谈论迦太基人是多么背信弃义、多么残忍。所以提迈奥斯，他似乎对活人祭祀有着无穷的兴趣。他绝对热爱这个话题，总是没完没了地提起。而提迈奥斯指控迦太基人最令人震惊的事情，或许就是他们长袍下穿着内裤。他们长袍下穿着内裤。是的。
Not like Scotsmen. Right. Okay. Did Greeks not wear underpants, Tom? Apparently not. I don't believe that. I think they probably did. Tobias condemns it as absolutely shocking behavior. I find that implausible. So just to step back a second for people who are completely bewildered where we are and what we're talking about. So I'm at the city of Carthage, which flourishes from very roughly its dates, Tom? 9th century up to the 2nd century.
不像苏格兰人。好吧。希腊人不穿内裤吗，汤姆？显然不穿。我不相信。我想他们可能穿的。波利比乌斯谴责这是一种绝对令人震惊的行为。我觉得这不可信。所以，为了让那些对我们身处何地、谈论什么感到困惑的人稍微理清一下思路。我是在迦太基城，它繁荣的时间大致是，汤姆，从什么时候开始？公元前9世纪一直到公元前2世纪。
So it becomes one of the great superpowers of the Mediterranean, this maritime power, very mercantile. And the thing about it, so going back to that reading, Carthage going up in flames, the thing that gives Carthage this enduring, one of the things anyway that gives it this enduring glamour and mystery is that almost everything is destroyed. Now you said last time that there are some stones and stuff left in Tunis,
所以它成为了地中海最伟大的超级大国之一，这是一个海上强国，非常商业化。关于它的一点是，回到那段阅读，迦太基陷入火海，赋予迦太基这种持久的——或者说赋予它持久魅力和神秘感的因素之一，就是几乎一切都被摧毁了。你上次说突尼斯还有一些石头之类的东西，
pretty much on the site of Carthage. But all its library is destroyed, everything written by the Carthaginians. We're told that they're given away to a people in Libya, a famous horseman called Numidians. The story goes that they give it away. The one collection of books that the Romans do keep is a 28-volume treatise on agriculture. That's depressing.
基本就在迦太基的原址上。但它所有的图书馆都被毁了，迦太基人写的一切都被毁了。我们被告知，这些东西被送给了利比亚的一个民族，著名的骑手努米底亚人。故事说他们把这些书送人了。罗马人唯一保留的一套书是关于农业的28卷论著。那真令人沮丧。
No, but apparently the Carthaginians were tremendous agronomists. Right. And as you say, there's this story that it gets sown with salt, the ruins get sown with salt. This isn't actually true. It actually got invented in 1920. Oh. And it's now been repeated over and over again.
不，但显然迦太基人是了不起的农学家。没错。正如你所说，有一个传说说它被撒上了盐，废墟被撒上了盐。这其实不是真的。它实际上是1920年才编造出来的。哦。现在它被一遍又一遍地重复。
Right. And there are kind of places. So we talked about the Tophet, the place where they did the child sacrifices in the previous episode, and that kind of got buried beneath kind of the rubble of the city, which the Romans used as filler for new settlements. So there are fragments of it, but there's not a huge amount. Right.
没错。还有一些地方。我们在上一集谈到了托菲特（Tophet），也就是他们进行活人祭祀的地方，它被埋在了城市的瓦砾之下，罗马人将其用作新定居点的填充物。所以有一些碎片，但数量并不多。没错。
I mean, you have to try and stop seeing it through Roman, and perhaps particularly Greek eyes, because the Greeks did kind of respect Carthage as almost being on a level with the Greeks themselves. And there was no higher source of praise. So Aristotle, for instance, he has a list of all the various constitutions of cities and Carthage is the only non-Greek city to be included in that. He actually rates Carthage very highly. He ranks it with Sparta and Crete as one of the top three constitutions in the world. So there are kind of positive takes as well. But of course, it's really important to emphasize that Carthage is not just a kind of ersatz, Greek city. It's Phoenician. Yeah, because you talked about that in the last episode. So the Phoenicians who are these people from modern day Lebanon, Tyre and Sidon. Yeah. You think they did
我的意思是，你必须试着停止通过罗马人，或许特别是希腊人的眼睛来看待它，因为希腊人确实在某种程度上尊重迦太基，认为它几乎与希腊人处于同一水平。没有比这更高的赞美了。所以亚里士多德，例如，他列出了所有城市的各种政体，迦太基是唯一被列入其中的非希腊城市。他实际上对迦太基评价很高。他将其与斯巴达和克里特岛并列为世界上最好的三个政体之一。所以也有一些积极的看法。但当然，非常重要的一点是，迦太基不仅仅是一个仿制的希腊城市。它是腓尼基的。是的，因为你在上一集谈到了这一点。所以腓尼基人，这些来自现代黎巴嫩、推罗和西顿的人。是的。你认为他们
exist. Some historians kind of think they're invented. But you and other historians think that there was a kind of commonality of identity among those Lebanese people. And that still matters in Carthage. They're still very conscious of themselves as descended in the same way that Americans would look to Great Britain. Same kind of relationship, Tom. So you think about the most famous Carthaginian of all is Hannibal, who leads an army against the Romans, elephants over the Alps. I mean, that literally means the grace of Baal. So Baal is the Lord. So the grace of the Lord. And that is one of really only a handful of names that the Carthaginian elite seem to have used and which derive from Tyre.
存在。一些历史学家认为他们是虚构的。但你和其他历史学家认为，那些黎巴嫩人之间存在一种共同的身份认同。这在迦太基仍然很重要。他们仍然非常自觉地认为自己是后裔，就像美国人看待英国一样。同样的关系，汤姆。所以你想到最著名的迦太基人是汉尼拔，他带领军队对抗罗马人，大象翻越阿尔卑斯山。我的意思是，那字面意思就是“巴力的恩典”。所以巴力是主。所以主的恩典。这确实是迦太基精英似乎使用过的少数几个名字之一，并且源自推罗。
And it makes it very, very annoying because there are multiple people. They've all got the same name. Right. There are waves upon waves of Hanno's who appear throughout Carthaginian history. So we'll have to try and negotiate that. And are we going to get more child sacrifice in today's episode? No, we're not. Oh. But listeners can be reassured that the very final section of this series,
这让人非常非常恼火，因为有很多人。他们都叫同一个名字。没错。迦太基历史上不断出现一波又一波的汉诺（Hanno）。所以我们必须试着处理这个问题。我们今天的节目里会有更多的活人祭祀吗？不，不会。哦。但听众可以放心，本系列的最后一部分，
there's some sensational torture to look forward to. So all kinds of atrocities. Okay, brilliant. We love a bit of sensational torture. So should we go through the sweep of Carthage's history? I would love nothing more, Tom. Good. So again, we talked about this in the previous episode. The traditional date of Carthage's founding is 814, and it's absolutely not implausible. And it is called the new city, Carthage in Phoenician, which implies that it is founded to be a city, to be a kind of permanent colonial settlement.
有一些耸人听闻的酷刑值得期待。所以各种各样的暴行。好的，太棒了。我们喜欢一点耸人听闻的酷刑。那么我们应该回顾一下迦太基的历史吗？我再乐意不过了，汤姆。好。所以同样，我们在上一集谈到了这一点。迦太基的传统建立日期是公元前814年，这绝对不是不可信的。它被称为“新城”，在腓尼基语中就是迦太基，这意味着它被建立为一座城市，成为一种永久的殖民定居点。
And I think the reason for that is that its location is tremendously advantageous. So as you said, it's just north of where Tunis is now. So it's that bit of Africa that sticks out towards Sicily. And its location is very, very advantageous. So it's a bit like Constantinople. There's a peninsula that sticks out. So it's defensible, but it is also large enough that there is room for expansion. I believe, Tom, you can get a light rail now that goes along the peninsula and all the stops are called kind of Hamilcar.
我认为原因在于它的地理位置极其优越。正如你所说，它就在现在突尼斯以北。所以它是非洲那块向西西里岛突出的部分。它的位置非常非常优越。所以它有点像君士坦丁堡。有一个半岛突出来。所以它既易于防守，又足够大，有扩张的空间。我相信，汤姆，你现在可以乘坐轻轨沿着半岛行驶，所有的站点都叫什么哈米尔卡（Hamilcar）之类的。
Oh, that's so romantic. I've never actually been. Have you not? So to give people a sense of it, you get this sort of little railway stroke tram thing out of the centre of Tunis, which I have to say I don't massively recommend. And every now and again you get off. The various stops, they'll say, brilliant Carthaginian site here. And I went with a former girlfriend who it's fair to say
哦，那太浪漫了。我从来没去过。你没去过吗？所以为了让人们有个概念，你从突尼斯市中心乘坐那种小火车或电车，我必须说我不太推荐。你时不时下车。各个站点会说，这里有很棒的迦太基遗址。我和一位前女友一起去过，可以说
was not a massive convert to Carthaginian history. Punic history. So we'd kind of get off this and we'd walked a little bit and there was like a sort of what looked like a kind of disused bit of waste ground and a load of old stones hanging around. Oh, I love it. I can't believe I haven't taken my children on a holiday there. And a very sort of garbled little caption would say,
她并不是迦太基历史的忠实拥趸。布匿历史。所以我们下车走了一小段路，那里看起来像是一块废弃的空地，到处都是旧石头。哦，我喜欢。真不敢相信我还没带我的孩子们去那里度假。然后一个非常含糊的小说明牌会说，
possibly child sacrifice things, who knows? You know, and that was it. I wouldn't say I was held in massively high regard by my travelling companion during that holiday. I know, but Dominic, imagine that you were back there in the eighth century, shortly after its founding. That was what I was saying, Tom. That was what I was saying. And you've got the Acropolis in front of you. So this was called the Birsa, which in Greek means oxide. And so they had this story that Daida, when she landed, she was allowed by the local king to have as much space as could be covered by an oxide.
可能是活人祭祀的东西，谁知道呢？你知道，就是这样。在那次假期里，我的旅伴对我评价不高。我知道，但多米尼克，想象一下你回到了8世纪，就在它建立后不久。我说的就是这个，汤姆。我说的就是这个。你面前有卫城。这被称为比尔萨（Birsa），在希腊语中意为“牛皮”。所以他们有一个故事，说狄多登陆时，当地国王允许她拥有牛皮所能覆盖的空间。
And so she cuts it into tiny slices and puts it around the beer cellar. I think I've heard that story about 20 different cities. I know. And it's definitely not true because actually the name derives from an Akkadian word for fortress. So, but it's a nice story. And of course it has harbours, spectacular harbours. And this is really why they settle it. But the other thing is that it is perfectly situated to dominate two alternative trade routes. So one, obviously from Phoenicia in the east, right the way up to Spain in the west, but also just as crucially, north-south. So you've got Sicily, very accessible just across the sea. And then, of course, you've got Italy. So Carthage is perfectly placed to control all this kind of trade. And as a result of this, it grows very fast. And so archaeologists looking at all these fascinating sites that you visited with your girlfriend, estimate that probably within a century of its founding, there may be 30, 40,000 people.
于是她把它切成细条，围住了比尔萨。我想我听过大约20个不同城市都有这个故事。我知道。这绝对不是真的，因为这个名字实际上源自阿卡德语中的“堡垒”。所以，但这确实是个好故事。当然，它有港口，壮观的港口。这确实是他们定居的原因。但另一件事是，它完美地坐落在控制两条替代贸易路线的位置上。所以一条显然是从东方的腓尼基一直到西方的西班牙，但同样关键的是南北方向。所以你有西西里岛，就在海对面，非常容易到达。然后，当然，你有意大利。所以迦太基处于控制所有这些贸易的完美位置。因此，它增长得非常快。所以考古学家看着你和女朋友参观的所有这些迷人的遗址，估计在建立后的一个世纪内，可能就有3万到4万人。
And it expands so fast that the walls keep having to be knocked down and rebuilt to make room for people. And just, you mentioned agronomy. So the sort of hinterland is very fertile. And actually, you see that today in Tunisia. You know, people probably haven't been to North Africa think, oh, it's probably all desert. It's absolutely not. It's kind of olive groves and lovely fields and all that kind of thing. Yes.
它扩张得如此之快，以至于城墙不得不不断拆除和重建，以容纳人口。你提到了农学。所以腹地非常肥沃。实际上，你今天在突尼斯还能看到这一点。你知道，人们可能没去过北非，认为那里全是沙漠。绝对不是。那里有橄榄树林、美丽的田野和所有这类东西。是的。
And it actually takes time for the Carthaginians to develop this. Because to begin with, I think they definitely remain a trading power. They're not particularly expanding into the hinterland, because there are tribes there. Yeah, Bedouin, Tom, surely, or Berbers or something. Berbers, yeah. Libyans, they're called. Or the Numidians, who we also mentioned. So I think to begin with, it's primarily a trading city. And so this is why Carthage itself, of course, is a colonial settlement, but they
迦太基人实际上花了一些时间才发展出这一点。因为起初，我认为他们绝对仍然是一个贸易强国。他们并没有特别向腹地扩张，因为那里有部落。是的，贝都因人，汤姆，肯定是，或者柏柏尔人什么的。柏柏尔人，是的。利比亚人，他们被称为利比亚人。或者努米底亚人，我们也提到过。所以我认为起初，它主要是一个贸易城市。这就是为什么迦太基本身当然是一个殖民定居点，但他们
then start going out and planting settlements across the Western Mediterranean, particularly on Sardinia. These are not towns, these are just trading posts. Rather like the settlements that the Venetians would have put up later, or the Portuguese in Africa. So sort of forts and markets, basically. Yes. As with the Portuguese settlements, there's a kind of underpinning of violence. So it's kind of bad news for the locals, really. Right. And so by the 6th century, Carthage is no longer colonial relative to Phoenicia. And in part, that's because back in Phoenicia, the Babylonians have conquered Tyre. So there's been a long 13
然后开始走出去，在地中海西部建立定居点，特别是在撒丁岛。这些不是城镇，这些只是贸易站。就像威尼斯人后来建立的定居点，或者葡萄牙人在非洲建立的定居点一样。所以基本上就是堡垒和市场。是的。正如葡萄牙人的定居点一样，有一种暴力的基础。所以这对当地人来说确实是个坏消息。没错。所以到了6世纪，迦太基相对于腓尼基不再是殖民地了。部分原因是回到腓尼基，巴比伦人已经征服了推罗。所以经历了一场漫长的13
year siege. Nebuchadnezzar takes control of it, the guy who will go on to conquer Jerusalem. And at the same time, there's a kind of collapse in the price of silver because the Phoenicians have been mining all this silver in Spain and there's a glut. And so basically the Tyrian economy implodes. Inflation, Tom. Galloping inflation, as with Spain, when they discover silver. And so this leaves the field open for Carthage to basically displace the mother country. So again, a bit like America and Britain, I guess. So a sad story. But it's imperialism. It's still very
年的围攻。尼布甲尼撒控制了它，就是那个后来征服耶路撒冷的人。与此同时，白银价格出现了崩溃，因为腓尼基人在西班牙开采了所有这些白银，导致了供过于求。所以基本上推罗经济崩溃了。通货膨胀，汤姆。飞速的通货膨胀，就像西班牙发现白银时一样。所以这让迦太基有机会基本上取代母国。所以同样，有点像美国和英国，我想。所以是一个悲伤的故事。但这是帝国主义。它仍然非常
Venetian. It's not, say, like the Romans, conquering territory. It's still planting settlements and kind of constructing trade nodes. But there is a straw in the wind at this point, because there's a kind of garbled account in both the Greek and the Roman sources, writing much later, of a guy called Malchus. And that has a hint of the Phoenician word for king. And he is supposed to have campaigned very hard in Sicily and Sardinia. And his exploits seem to be slightly exaggerated, but it does suggest that the Greeks are starting to arrive on the scene now. So the Carthaginians have had it all their way, but now the Greeks are turning up and starting to compete for resources in Sicily,
腓尼基。它不像罗马人那样征服领土。它仍然是在建立定居点和构建贸易节点。但此时出现了一个预兆，因为在后来撰写的希腊和罗马史料中，有一个关于一个叫马尔库斯（Malchus）的人的含糊记载。这带有腓尼基语中“国王”一词的暗示。据说他在西西里岛和撒丁岛进行了非常艰苦的战役。他的事迹似乎被稍微夸大了，但这确实表明希腊人现在开始出现在现场了。所以迦太基人一直顺风顺水，但现在希腊人出现了，并开始在西西里岛争夺资源，
in Sardinia, in Southern Gaul, in Spain. So at this point in the Mediterranean, there is no, as it were, superpower. It's all up for grabs, right? Nobody is sophisticated and powerful enough. Well, Carthage is the most powerful city. Even at this stage? Yes, absolutely. Yeah. And has been accustomed to having its own way on the kind of the trade front for a fair
在撒丁岛，在南高卢，在西班牙。所以此时在地中海，没有所谓的超级大国。一切都待价而沽，对吧？没有人足够复杂和强大。好吧，迦太基是最强大的城市。即使在这个阶段？是的，绝对。是的，而且在贸易方面已经习惯了随心所欲
while. Right. Which is why the arrival of the Greeks, particularly in Sicily, is so destabilizing. So in the 730s, the most significant Greek city in Sicily is founded, and that's Syracuse, which of course is still there. I mean, kind of wonderfully situated. And so Syracuse is squaring up to Phoenician cities that have been founded in the East. So the most significant of these is Panormus, which is today Palermo. So these are cities that are being founded in places that are
一段时间了。没错。这就是为什么希腊人的到来，特别是在西西里岛，是如此具有破坏性。所以730年代，西西里岛最重要的希腊城市建立了，那就是叙拉古（Syracuse），当然它现在还在。我的意思是，位置非常美妙。所以叙拉古正在与东方建立的腓尼基城市对峙。所以其中最重要的是帕诺尔穆斯（Panormus），也就是今天的巴勒莫。所以这些城市建立在那些
kind of absolutely perfect for cities so panormous is actually the greek name for it brilliantly the phoenician name seems to have been ziz ziz that's a brilliant name apparently it means flower right so it's such a shame it's not still called ziz and the other very significant phoenician settlement is a place called mochia which we mentioned in the previous episode as having a top tophet, top place for child sacrifice. And a bit like Tyre, it's on an island. And so archaeologists have been able to look at it. They know what it was like in the 6th century. It had kind of incredible dry docks, temples, had a tophet, of course, industrial zones. And again, it was involved in making dye. So this involves smashing up mollusks and leaving them to dry in the sun. And also it's making garum, which is this kind of fish-based sauce. So I think you could assume that Phoenician cities stank. I mean, you can imagine drying mollusks and drying fish. I mean, that's quite hard. But would they stink more than others,
非常适合建城的地方。所以帕诺尔穆斯实际上是它的希腊名字，非常棒，腓尼基名字似乎是“齐兹”（Ziz）。齐兹，那是个很棒的名字。显然它意味着“花”，对吧？所以它不再叫齐兹真是太可惜了。另一个非常重要的腓尼基定居点是一个叫莫蒂亚（Mochia）的地方，我们在上一集提到过它有一个托菲特，活人祭祀的顶级场所。它有点像推罗，在一个岛上。所以考古学家已经能够研究它。他们知道它在6世纪是什么样子。它有令人难以置信的干船坞、神庙、当然还有一个托菲特、工业区。同样，它参与了染料制造。这涉及粉碎软体动物并让它们在阳光下晾干。它还制造加鲁姆（garum），这是一种鱼酱。所以我认为你可以假设腓尼基城市很臭。我的意思是，你可以想象晾干软体动物和鱼。我的意思是，那很难闻。但它们会比其他城市更臭吗，
Tom? That's the question. So surely Greeks, it is, would have had their own stench, wouldn't they? But the Phoenicians control the dye market. The Greeks never really work out how to do that. So I think that adds a kind of extra dimension. Extra level, yeah. So Pernomus and Mochia, they're not subject to Carthage, but obviously they're under Carthaginian influence. And the sense that Phoenician settlements in Western Sicily are going to be absorbed into a Carthaginian sphere of influence intensifies because, of course, the Greeks are spreading from Eastern Sicily westwards, and they are starting to crash into the Carthaginian sphere of influence, the Phoenician sphere of influence. So by 600, you are getting cities that are almost going toe to toe with the Phoenicians. So you have a place called Salinas on the south
汤姆？这就是问题所在。所以希腊人肯定也有他们自己的恶臭，不是吗？但腓尼基人控制了染料市场。希腊人从未真正弄清楚如何做到这一点。所以我认为这增加了一种额外的维度。额外的层面，是的。所以帕诺尔穆斯和莫蒂亚，它们不隶属于迦太基，但显然它们处于迦太基的影响之下。西西里岛西部的腓尼基定居点将被纳入迦太基势力范围的感觉加剧了，因为当然，希腊人正在从西西里岛东部向西扩张，他们开始撞上迦太基的势力范围，腓尼基的势力范围。所以到了600年，你开始有城市几乎要与腓尼基人正面交锋了。所以你在西西里岛南岸有一个叫塞利努斯（Salinas）的地方，
coast of Sicily and a place called Himera on the north coast. And in 580, Greek colonists try to build a city directly opposite Mochia on its island. The Phoenicians, they form an alliance, Carthaginians join in, they drive the Greek colonists away. And the result of this is that Mochia improves its defences, but so also does the Greek city of Salinas. So there's a sense that a cold war is really starting to hot up. Do we know about this from archaeology? Because you mentioned improving their defences. And also we know about it from historians because Herodotus, this is kind of almost within living memory. And so he writes about this, but he also writes particularly about a city on the eastern seaboard of what's now
在北岸有一个叫希梅拉（Himera）的地方。公元580年，希腊殖民者试图在莫蒂亚对面的岛上直接建立一座城市。腓尼基人结成联盟，迦太基人加入，他们赶走了希腊殖民者。结果是莫蒂亚改善了防御，但塞利努斯的希腊城市也改善了。所以有一种冷战真的开始升温的感觉。我们是通过考古学知道这一点的吗？因为你提到了改善防御。而且我们通过历史学家也知道这一点，因为希罗多德，这几乎还在活人的记忆中。所以他写到了这一点，但他还特别写到了现在土耳其东海岸的一座城市，
Turkey. So on the Aegean coast called Phakia, the amusingly named Phakia. And the Persians have arrived on the scene and they have conquered the Greek cities on the eastern Aegean. And the Phakians are besieged. They all get into their ships while the Persian siege works are outside. They sail off west. And so when the Persians break in, the city is empty and deserted. And so the Phicians head westwards, they sail into the Western Mediterranean. And basically, you know, they are operating as pirates because by this point there are Greek cities that they've been planted in Corsica and in southern Gaul.
在爱琴海沿岸，叫福西亚（Phakia），名字很有趣的福西亚。波斯人出现在现场，征服了爱琴海东部的希腊城市。福西亚人被围困。当波斯人的围攻工程在外面时，他们都上了船。他们航行离开。所以当波斯人破门而入时，城市空无一人。所以福西亚人向西航行，他们驶入地中海西部。基本上，你知道，他们作为海盗活动，因为此时已经有希腊城市种植在科西嘉岛和南高卢。
So Nice is originally Nicaea and Marseille is originally Marsilia. They are Greek cities. And the Phicians are just sailing around acting like pirates, preying on Carthaginian ships. So the Carthaginians ally themselves with a people called the Etruscans who are in northern Italy. They've given their name to Tuscany. Yeah, of course. And the Etruscans and the Carthaginians, they make an enormous fleet.
所以尼斯（Nice）最初是尼西亚（Nicaea），马赛（Marseille）最初是马西利亚（Marsilia）。它们是希腊城市。福西亚人只是四处航行，像海盗一样行事，掠夺迦太基船只。所以迦太基人与意大利北部的一个民族结盟，他们叫伊特鲁里亚人（Etruscans）。他们给了托斯卡纳这个名字。是的，当然。伊特鲁里亚人和迦太基人，他们组成了一支庞大的舰队。
They sail out. They fight the Phicians in a battle that comes to be called the Battle of the Sardinian Sea. And although both sides suffer heavy losses, the Phicians have the worst of it. Lots of them are taken prisoner and the Etruscans take them back to Tuscany or Etruria, we should probably call it,
他们航行出去。他们在后来被称为撒丁海战的战斗中与福西亚人作战。尽管双方都遭受了惨重损失，但福西亚人损失最惨重。许多人被俘，伊特鲁里亚人把他们带回托斯卡纳，或者我们应该叫它伊特鲁里亚，
and stone them to death. Tom, before you move on, one fact for you about this settling of French cities. take them back to Tuscany or Etruria, we should probably call it, and stone them to death. Tom, before you move on, one fact for you about this settling of French cities. The nickname for Olympique de Marseille, the football team, is still, I believe, the Phoenicians. Is it? Yeah, I think so. I didn't know that. That's wonderful.
并用石头把他们砸死。汤姆，在你继续之前，关于这些法国城市的定居，有一个事实告诉你。把他们带回托斯卡纳，或者我们应该叫它伊特鲁里亚，并用石头把他们砸死。汤姆，在你继续之前，关于这些法国城市的定居，有一个事实告诉你。马赛奥林匹克足球队的绰号仍然是“腓尼基人”。是吗？是的，我想是这样。我不知道。那太棒了。
I can remember seeing that in Les Quipes or something in the 1990s and being completely baffled by it. Theo, our producer, says it is indeed a terrible team. Well, that's a sorry reflection on the decline of the Phoenicians. Yeah. Very sad. When I saw them, they had Tony Cascarino playing for them, Tom. Goodness. A fake Irishman.
我记得在90年代的《队报》之类的报纸上看到过，完全被搞糊涂了。我们的制片人西奥说，这确实是一支糟糕的球队。好吧，那是对腓尼基人衰落的悲哀反映。是的。非常悲伤。我看到他们的时候，托尼·卡斯卡里诺（Tony Cascarino）在为他们效力，汤姆。天哪。一个假爱尔兰人。
Anyway, that's by the by. Well, the Irish also falsely claimed to be descended from Phoenicians. Really? In the 18th century, yeah. It all connects. It does all connect. That's the case for renowned novelist Dan Brown. Yes. To get his teeth into there. So basically the Carthaginians I think are absolutely holding their own. They're seeing off Greek trade rivals. They are keeping
总之，那是题外话。好吧，爱尔兰人也曾错误地声称自己是腓尼基人的后裔。真的吗？在18世纪，是的。这一切都联系在一起。确实都联系在一起。这就是著名小说家丹·布朗（Dan Brown）的素材。是的，让他去钻研吧。所以基本上我认为迦太基人绝对在坚持自己的立场。他们正在送走希腊贸易竞争对手。他们正在保持
the Western Mediterranean shipping lanes under their control. And what they are also starting to do by this point is what you alluded to earlier, that they are colonizing the African lands that lie beyond the city itself. So probably up until the 6th century, they'd been dependent on Sardinia for food imports. I mean, that's basically why they'd kind of set up settlements there, because they could grow the kind of staples that they needed. But certainly by the 6th century, it's clear from archaeological remains that the foodstuffs that they are using in Carthage are mainly coming from their own backyard. And they can do this basically for two reasons. So one is that they now have the money that they can afford mercenaries and thereby subdue the Libyan tribes in the hinterland, subordinate them.
地中海西部的航道处于他们的控制之下。而且他们此时也开始做你之前提到的事情，那就是他们正在殖民城市本身之外的非洲土地。所以可能直到6世纪，他们一直依赖撒丁岛进口粮食。我的意思是，这基本上就是他们在那建立定居点的原因，因为他们可以种植他们需要的必需品。但肯定到了6世纪，从考古遗迹中可以清楚地看出，迦太基使用的食品主要来自他们自己的后院。他们基本上可以出于两个原因做到这一点。所以一个是他们现在有钱了，可以雇佣雇佣兵，从而征服腹地的利比亚部落，使他们从属。
And the other is what we alluded to earlier this agrarian revolution so the 28 volumes of agricultural know-how that the romans saved this was written by a guy called mago and he basically for the romans is synonymous with making the desert bloom so he is the first guy to as far as know, advocate the regular use of fertilizers, the pruning of trees, so olives and so on, of vines. And Carthage becomes very famous for its sweet wines, also for its fruit. So the Romans know the pomegranate, for instance, as the Marlon punicum, the Carthaginian apple. And they're very technologically adept when it comes to agriculture. So there's this kind of weird threshing machine, which comes to be known by the Romans as a punic cart. They're very good at irrigation.
另一个就是我们之前提到的农业革命，所以罗马人保存的28卷农业知识，这是由一个叫马戈（Mago）的人写的，他基本上对罗马人来说是让沙漠开花的代名词。所以他是据我们所知第一个提倡定期使用肥料、修剪树木（如橄榄等）、葡萄藤的人。迦太基以其甜酒和水果而闻名。所以罗马人知道石榴，例如，叫“马伦·普尼库姆”（Marlon punicum），即迦太基苹果。他们在农业方面技术非常娴熟。所以有一种奇怪的脱粒机，后来被罗马人称为“布匿车”。他们非常擅长灌溉。
They love a bath. That's perhaps because of the smelling issue, Tom. Yes, exactly. Yes, you walk past all that garum and you need to have a wash. So Tom, just stop you a second. Yeah. You're talking about the hinterland. The African hinterland, it says in your notes.
他们喜欢洗澡。那可能是因为气味问题，汤姆。是的，完全正确。是的，你走过所有那些加鲁姆，你需要洗个澡。所以汤姆，停一下。是的。你在谈论腹地。非洲腹地，你的笔记里写着。
So here's a question for you. If we've got any American academics who listen to this podcast, they will undoubtedly be thinking of this question. Is there any meaningful sense in which the Carthaginians, other than those purely sort of starkly geographical, is there any sense in which they are African? Africa at this point, I mean, the Roman province of Africa is, I mean, essentially the kind of the lands that were ruled by Carthage. So in that sense, Carthage is the capital of Africa. The word Africa for the Romans wouldn't have the sense that it has for us of this vast continent. So yeah, I mean, Carthage as Phoenician, as we've said, but there are Phoenician settlements in Sicily, in Africa, in Spain. They preserve their Phoenician identity, but of course they're aware of the geographical context that they're in.
所以这里有一个问题。如果我们有任何美国学者听这个播客，他们无疑会想到这个问题。迦太基人在除了纯粹地理意义之外，还有任何有意义的意义上是“非洲人”吗？此时的非洲，我的意思是，罗马的非洲行省，我的意思是，本质上是迦太基统治的土地。所以从这个意义上说，迦太基是非洲的首都。罗马人的“非洲”一词并没有我们现在所理解的这片广阔大陆的含义。所以是的，我的意思是，迦太基是腓尼基的，正如我们所说，但在西西里岛、非洲、西班牙都有腓尼基定居点。他们保留了他们的腓尼基身份，但当然他们意识到他们所处的地理环境。
But when they think of the world, they're basically looking outwards to the Mediterranean. They're not looking backwards. I mean, the Sahara is behind them. Do they have sub-Saharan links? This is why they are sending ships out through the Straits of Gibraltar. They're always looking to the sea. Right. That is how they trade.
但当他们思考世界时，他们基本上是向外看地中海。他们不是向后看。我的意思是，撒哈拉沙漠在他们身后。他们有撒哈拉以南的联系吗？这就是为什么他们派遣船只穿过直布罗陀海峡。他们总是看着大海。没错。那就是他们贸易的方式。
Right. The lands that lie behind Carthage, heading inland, are there basically to sustain and feed Carthage and to provide it with troops, with mercenaries. Yeah. But I think their ultimate loyalties is always with the sea. And just one last question on this front. I know this is probably a very difficult question to answer, but as it were, ethnically, they are still the descendants
没错。迦太基身后的土地，向内陆延伸，基本上是为了维持和养活迦太基，并为它提供军队、雇佣兵。是的。但我认为他们最终的忠诚总是属于大海。关于这一点最后一个问题。我知道这可能是一个非常难回答的问题，但作为，民族上，他们仍然是
of the Phoenician settlers or settlers from elsewhere in the Mediterranean. So presumably, again, not, I mean, there might well be some admixture with kind of sub-Saharan migrants or something, but probably not great. All these people are calling themselves Hannibal and Hanno, the elites. These are the Phoenician equivalent of wasps. Oh, white Anglo-Saxon Protestants. Or people in 19th century New York who claim Dutch heritage. These are people who are very, very aware of their pedigree and very, very proud of it. But of course, Carthage is a great teeming cosmopolitan city. So there are people drawn from across the Mediterranean. There are
腓尼基定居者或来自地中海其他地方的定居者的后裔。所以大概，我的意思是，可能确实有一些与撒哈拉以南移民之类的混血，但可能不多。所有这些人都在叫汉尼拔和汉诺，精英们。这些是腓尼基版的“盎格鲁-撒克逊白人新教徒”（WASP）。哦。或者19世纪纽约声称有荷兰血统的人。这些人非常非常清楚自己的血统，并为此感到非常非常自豪。但当然，迦太基是一座伟大的、熙熙攘攘的国际化城市。所以有来自地中海各地的人。有
people from the interior of Africa. It is a great melting pot in that sense, but it absolutely retains its Phoenician identity. Absolutely. And actually it is kind of, if there's such a word, punicising, Phoenicianising the interior, because by the fifth century, thanks to Mago and his threshing machines and his, you know, his fertiliser and all that kind of stuff. What had previously been scrub is really starting to bloom. Greek visitors from Sicily marvel at the fecundity of it. To quote, the beauty of the land is prosperity. There are gardens everywhere, there are orchards, there are irrigation channels filling what had previously been dry and barren with flowing water. And so you were getting country estates, the equivalent of the villas that Roman aristocrats start to
来自非洲内陆的人。从这个意义上说，它是一个伟大的熔炉，但它绝对保留了它的腓尼基身份。绝对。而且实际上，如果有一个这样的词，它正在“布匿化”、“腓尼基化”内陆，因为到了5世纪，多亏了马戈和他的脱粒机，以及他的肥料和所有这类东西。曾经是灌木丛的地方真的开始开花了。来自西西里岛的希腊游客对它的肥沃感到惊叹。引用一句，“土地之美即是繁荣”。到处都是花园，有果园，有灌溉渠，将曾经干旱贫瘠的地方填满了流动的河水。所以你有了乡村庄园，相当于罗马贵族开始在罗马城外建造的别墅。你也能找到这些。到处都是种马场和牲畜。所以一个在，我不知道，5世纪初访问迦太基的希腊游客会知道他正在访问一座拥有令人印象深刻和令人生畏力量的城市。它非常美丽。它相当异国情调，而且它是一个潜在的威胁。同样，这回到了我们在节目开始时谈到的，对于希腊人来说，迦太基是一个充满神秘和恐惧的地方。哇，太令人兴奋了。所以汤姆，了解更多关于谁统治迦太基、迦太基政治以及迦太基帝国主义漫长而戏剧性的历史将会非常迷人。休息后我们再谈这个。
build outside Rome. You're finding these as well. And you're getting stud farms and you're getting livestock everywhere. So a Greek visitor to Carthage in, say, I don't know, the very early fifth century would know that he was visiting a city of impressive and intimidating power. It's very beautiful. It's pretty exotic and it is potentially a menace. And again, this goes back to what we were talking about at the start of the program, that for the Greeks, Carthage is a place of mystery and fear. Wow, exciting. So Tom, it will be fascinating to know a little bit more about who ruled Carthage, Carthaginian politics, and the long and dramatic history of Carthaginian imperialism. Let's do that after the break.
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是您每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们将揭开娱乐界的帷幕，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。我得到可靠消息，当战斗开始，哈米尔卡处于劣势时，他从地球表面消失了，
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com I've been reliably informed that when battle was joined and Hamilcar was having the worst of it, he disappeared off the face of the earth
再也没有人见过他活着或死去。迦太基人自己给出的解释，而且也不无道理，是野蛮人和希腊人之间的战斗从黎明一直持续到深夜，哈米尔卡在整个冲突期间都待在营地里，为了寻求有利的预兆，他在巨大的柴堆上献祭了整具祭品。当他把奠酒倒在上面时，他看到他的军队溃逃，于是他投身于火海。
and was never seen again alive or dead. The explanation for this, given by the Carthaginians themselves, and not implausibly as well, is that the battle between the barbarians and the Greeks dragged on from dawn until late afternoon, and that Hamilcar stayed for the entire duration of this clash in the camp, where in his attempt to secure favourable omens, he offered up the entire bodies of sacrificial victims on a massive pyre. And it so happened, as he was pouring libations onto them, that he saw his troops turning tail and he hurled himself onto the blaze.
他再也没有出现的原因是他已经被烧成了灰烬。这就是希罗多德关于希梅拉战役的记载，这场战役发生在公元前480年，交战双方是一支由当时的大人物哈米尔卡领导的迦太基军队，他最终自焚而死，以及一支来自叙拉古的军队，它是西西里岛伟大的贸易竞争对手，
The reason then that he was never seen again was because he had been burnt to ashes. So that's Herodotus' account of the Battle of Hymera, which was fought in the year 480 BC between a Carthaginian army, which was led by the great bigwig of the day, Hamilcar, ends up burning himself alive, and an army from Syracuse, its great trading rival in Sicily,
由它的暴君盖隆（Gellon）领导。是的。好名字。是的。所以，汤姆，此时叙拉古人和迦太基人是伟大的竞争对手。这是地中海伟大的德比战。重量级对决，多米尼克。重量级对决。
led by its tyrant who was called Gellon. Yes. Great name. Yeah. So, Tom, by this point, the Syracusians and the Carthaginians, they're the great rivals. This is the great Mediterranean derby. Heavyweight clash, Dominic. Heavyweight clash.
重量级对决。而叙拉古，我们现在认为它是一座意大利城市，西西里岛的。所以那是此时伟大的希腊城市。是这样吗？是的，在西西里岛。事实上，很可能在整个希腊世界都是如此，因为480年，当然是波斯国王薛西斯（Xerxes）入侵希腊的那一年。这一年也见证了温泉关战役和萨拉米斯海战。
Heavyweight clash. And Syracuse, which we now think of as an Italian city, Sicilian. So that's the big Greek city at this point. Is that right? Yes, in Sicily. And in fact, very possibly in the whole Greek world, because 480, of course, is the year that Xerxes, the Persian king, invades Greece. And this is the year that sees the Battle of Thermopylae and Salamis.
重量级的对决。我们现在认为锡拉库萨是一座意大利城市，西西里岛的城市。所以那是当时最大的希腊城市。是这样吗？是的，在西西里岛。事实上，很可能在整个希腊世界都是如此，因为公元前480年，当然是波斯国王薛西斯入侵希腊的那一年。这一年也见证了温泉关战役和萨拉米斯海战。
And before Xerxes invades, the Greeks in Greece itself, so Athens and Sparta particularly, know the Persians are coming. And so they send ambassadors to Syracuse to ask Galon if he will help them face the Persian onslaught. Galon doesn't really want to do it, but he doesn't want to seem like he's not standing by the Greeks in their hour of need. So he says, yeah, I'll do it, provided I can be commander in chief. And the Spartans are not having this, and so they refuse. So Herodotus says that actually Galon might still have come and helped the Greeks, had it not been for the fact that the Carthaginians that summer of 480 decided to launch a massive invasion of Sicily, so of Greek Sicily. And there's no question that the Battle of Himera,
在薛西斯入侵之前，希腊本土的希腊人，特别是雅典和斯巴达，就已经知道波斯人要来了。于是他们派遣使者前往叙拉古，询问盖隆是否愿意帮助他们抵御波斯的猛攻。盖隆其实并不想卷入其中，但他又不想表现得在希腊人危难时刻袖手旁观。所以他说，好吧，我愿意帮忙，前提是我必须担任总司令。斯巴达人对此无法接受，于是拒绝了。希罗多德说，如果不是因为迦太基人在公元前480年那个夏天决定对西西里岛——也就是希腊治下的西西里——发动大规模入侵，盖隆可能还是会去帮助希腊人的。毫无疑问，希梅拉战役，
which you read in that magnificent translation of Herodotus, was a really stunning Greek victory, because as far as we can tell, no Carthaginian force would invade Sicily again for about half a century after that. And of course, the eeriness of that account of Hamilcar vanishing, supposedly having thrown himself into the flames i mean again this is an absolute riff yeah the greeks are obsessed with the idea that the carthaginians are endlessly hurling things including their children into flames so there's a sense i think that hamilcar is condemning himself to a kind of tophet there that he's offering himself up as a living sacrifice so that's mysterious and this is the greek obsession with Carthaginians behaving in a kind of, they have the sense that the Carthaginians are unsettling.
正如你在希罗多德那部宏伟的译作中所读到的，是一场令人惊叹的希腊大胜，因为据我们所知，此后大约半个世纪里，没有任何迦太基军队再敢入侵西西里。当然，关于哈米尔卡消失的那段记载非常诡异，据说他投身火海——我的意思是，这绝对是一种夸张的说法。是的，希腊人痴迷于一种观念，即迦太基人不断地将东西，包括他们的孩子，扔进火里。所以我认为，人们有一种感觉，哈米尔卡是在那里将自己判处了一种“托菲特”式的刑罚，他将自己作为活祭品献祭。这很神秘，也体现了希腊人对迦太基人行为的执念，他们觉得迦太基人令人不安。
And alien and eerie. Weird, supernatural. Yeah, exactly. Okay. And there's a further sense of the uncanny about this battle of Himera, which is that numerous Greeks claim that the battle was fought on the same day as Salamis. So there's this kind of dovetailing of the Persian barbarians and the Car day as Salamis. So there's this kind of dovetailing of the Persian barbarians and the Carthaginian barbarians being defeated at the same time. And the claim is that the Carthaginians were invading Sicily to distract Syracuse and the other Greeks in Sicily from going to the rescue of Athens and Sparta, because the Tyrians are
既陌生又诡异。怪异，超自然。是的，没错。好吧。关于这场希梅拉战役，还有一种更深层的离奇感，那就是许多希腊人声称这场战役与萨拉米斯战役发生在同一天。所以，波斯蛮族和迦太基蛮族在同一时间被击败，这似乎是一种巧合。有人声称，迦太基人入侵西西里是为了分散叙拉古和其他西西里希腊人的注意力，使他们无法去救援雅典和斯巴达，因为泰尔人是
subjects of the Persian kings. And so there's been kind of liaison between the Persians and the Carthaginians. But that's perfectly plausible, right? I mean, it's perfectly plausible that ambassadors could have gone between the two, that they could have said, listen, we're attacking such and such a time. You know, why don't we do this? No, because I think the ulterior motive there very plainly is that Gaelon is trying to cast himself as a hero, kind of alongside Laenidas or whatever. Of course. But that doesn't mean that that couldn't have happened. I mean, people do collude all the time in history.
波斯国王的臣民。因此，波斯人和迦太基人之间似乎存在某种联络。但这完全说得通，对吧？我的意思是，使者在两者之间往来，他们可能说：“听着，我们在某个时间发动攻击。我们要不要一起行动？”这完全是合理的。不，因为我认为那里隐藏的动机非常明显，盖隆试图将自己塑造成英雄，就像列奥尼达那样。当然。但这并不意味着那件事不可能发生。我的意思是，历史上人们总是会勾结。
But we know enough about how this battle came to be fought that it's very clear that this was nothing to do with a kind of synchronized geopolitical clash of titans. Hamilcar is not launching an invasion in cahoots with Xerxes. What he's doing is he has a Greek ally called Teralus, who is the tyrant of Himera. They have a very kind of close bond, a sacred bond of guest friendship, as it was called. And this guy, Teralus, has been expelled by Galon's forces. He's been kicked out. And so Teralus goes to his friend, Hamilcar, and says, would you, you know, would you help me? And Hamilcar says, yeah, sure I would. And so Teroulas goes to his friend, Hamilcar, and says, would you help me? And Hamilcar says, yeah, sure I would. And of course, Hamilcar is doing it for strategic reasons. He knows how
但我们对这场战役的起因了解得足够多，很明显，这与某种同步的地缘政治泰坦之战毫无关系。哈米尔卡并不是与薛西斯串通一气发动入侵。他有一个希腊盟友叫特里洛斯，是希梅拉的僭主。他们之间有一种非常亲密的关系，即所谓的“宾主友谊”的神圣纽带。而这个特里洛斯被盖隆的军队驱逐了。他被赶走了。于是特里洛斯去找他的朋友哈米尔卡，说：“你能帮我吗？”哈米尔卡说：“好的，没问题。”当然，哈米尔卡这样做是有战略原因的。他知道
dangerous Galon is, not least because actually, and this shows how the idea of absolute division between Greeks and barbarians makes no sense because Hamilcar's mother is actually from Syracuse. So he knows the city very well. So he's half Greek. He's half Greek. But more significantly, he belongs to a clan called the Magonids. So descended from a guy called Mago. And it's this that enables him to do what he's doing because he's by miles the most powerful, wealthy, influential figure to the degree that he's described in many of the Greek sources as being a Basileus, a king. And he is operating kind of as a private citizen, going to the help of a friend, doing it for the good of his city at the same time. And that essentially is his motivation. And there's a sense, I think, that it's tremendous chutzpah from Galen, because Galen is a tyrant.
盖隆有多危险，尤其是——这表明希腊人和蛮族之间绝对分裂的观念是多么荒谬——哈米尔卡的母亲实际上来自叙拉古。所以他非常了解这座城市。所以他是半个希腊人。他是半个希腊人。但更重要的是，他属于一个叫马戈尼德的家族。所以他是马戈的后裔。正是这一点使他能够做他正在做的事情，因为他是无可争议的最强大、最富有、最有影响力的人物，以至于在许多希腊文献中，他被描述为“巴西琉斯”，即国王。他基本上是以私人身份行事，去帮助一个朋友，同时也为了他自己城市的利益。这基本上就是他的动机。而且我认为，盖隆表现得非常狂妄，因为盖隆是一个僭主。
He has crushed the democracy in Syracuse. There's no sense of that. He's made himself its sole leader. And it's Carthage which will go on to be praised by Aristotle for the perfection of its constitution, precisely because it's not subject to tyrants. Okay. So I'm absolutely sticking up for Carthage here. I think the idea that Himera is a kind of great battle won for the Greeks against barbarian despotism is shameful propaganda. Oh, good for Carthage. Yeah.
他粉碎了叙拉古的民主。根本没有那种东西。他让自己成为了唯一的领导者。而迦太基后来因其宪法的完美而受到亚里士多德的赞扬，恰恰是因为它不受僭主统治。好吧。所以我绝对是站在迦太基这一边的。我认为希梅拉战役是希腊人为反对蛮族专制而赢得的一场伟大胜利的说法，是可耻的宣传。哦，为迦太基叫好。是的。
Good for Carthage. Yeah. So, Tom, Aristotle loves his constitution. So it doesn't have a king, doesn't have an emperor, but it's not quite a republic. What is it? We're not entirely sure, partly because it evolves quite a lot, I think, over time. And partly also because, you know, the Romans got rid of all the Carthaginian writings. So we're reliant on the Greeks and the Romans for descriptions of it.
为迦太基叫好。是的。那么，汤姆，亚里士多德很推崇他们的宪法。所以它没有国王，没有皇帝，但它也不完全是一个共和国。那它是什么？我们不太确定，部分原因是我认为它随着时间的推移演变了很多。部分原因也是因为，你知道，罗马人销毁了所有迦太基的著作。所以我们只能依赖希腊人和罗马人的描述。
And they use their own words, which come freighted with all kinds of baggage. Yeah, of course. So Hamilcar, you know, is he a king? It's difficult to know because Herodotus says that he's a king, but he also says that he had become king of Carthage by virtue of his courage. So that suggests that he's kind of been elected. And Romans, when they talk about the dynasty of Mago, so the dynasty that Hamilcar belongs to, they use the word dux, which is a military leader or dictator, which of course is the office where,
他们使用自己的词汇，这些词汇带有各种各样的偏见。是的，当然。那么哈米尔卡，他是国王吗？很难知道，因为希罗多德说他是国王，但也说他凭借自己的勇气成为了迦太基的国王。这表明他似乎是被选举出来的。而罗马人在谈论马戈王朝——也就是哈米尔卡所属的王朝——时，他们使用“Dux”这个词，意为军事领袖或独裁者，这当然是
in times of emergency, a citizen is appointed to lead the state. So I think that whether there was a monarchy that got replaced by a kind of an appointed king substitute or whether there was never a monarchy and that was always what happened, we're not sure. But essentially the monarchical element is probably elective if they did have it. A strong man chosen by his peers. Yeah. Yeah. But I think what is definite is that there is a kind of dynastic quality to the authority that the family of Mago exercise. So interestingly, the reputation of Hamilcar, despite the defeat at Himera, it's not particularly blackened. The Magonid prestige doesn't seem to have been
在紧急情况下，任命一名公民来领导国家的职位。所以我认为，无论是否存在被某种任命的国王替代品所取代的君主制，还是从未有过君主制而一直如此，我们都不确定。但本质上，如果他们确实有君主制，那君主因素可能是选举产生的。由同僚选出的强人。是的。是的。但我认为可以肯定的是，马戈家族行使的权力具有某种王朝性质。有趣的是，尽管在希梅拉战败，哈米尔卡的声誉并没有特别受损。马戈尼德家族的威望似乎并没有
particularly impaired by it. And the Magonids remain the dominant dynasty in Carthage over the course of the fifth century. So it's likely that we talked about Hanno the Navigator. So he's one of the many Hanno's that will feature in this story. You remember the guy who sails out through the Pillars of Hercules, goes down the coast of Africa and sees what were maybe chimpanzees. So he was probably Hamilcar's son. And you said these are descended from a guy called Mago, but he's not the agronomist. The guy's writing about like crops. No, he's a different one. one this is the awful confusion there are only about 10 carthaginian names right no he's a different mago okay and then hano the navigator son hannibal but he's not
因此受到特别损害。马戈尼德家族在整个五世纪仍然是迦太基的统治王朝。所以我们谈到的航海家汉诺很可能就是其中之一。他是这个故事中会出现的众多汉诺之一。你还记得那个穿过赫拉克勒斯之柱，沿着非洲海岸航行，看到了可能是黑猩猩的家伙吗？所以他很可能是哈米尔卡的儿子。你说他们是马戈的后裔，但他不是那个农学家。那个写农作物书的人。不，他是另一个。这是一个可怕的混淆，迦太基名字只有大约10个，对吧？不，他是另一个马戈。好的，然后是航海家汉诺的儿子汉尼拔，但他不是
hannibal no he's not hannibal so he goes back on the attack in sicily and he gets a spectacular vengeance for himera so he captures selenus which, which is the Greek city on the south coast near the Venetian zone of influence, raises its walls completely and he captures Himera and he obliterates it from the face of the earth. Crikey. So, yeah. And he then, according to the Greeks, he rounds up 3,000 prisoners taken at Himera and he leads them to the place where Hamilcar is supposed to have immolated himself in the fire. And there he slaughters the lot of them.
汉尼拔，不，他不是汉尼拔。所以他回到西西里发动进攻，并为希梅拉之战进行了壮观的复仇。他占领了塞利努斯——那是威尼斯势力范围附近的南海岸希腊城市——彻底夷平了它的城墙，并占领了希梅拉，将其从地球表面抹去。天哪。所以，是的。然后，据希腊人说，他围捕了在希梅拉俘获的3000名囚犯，并将他们带到哈米尔卡据称投身火海的地方。在那里，他将他们全部屠杀。
Oh my word, Tom, very strong stuff. As a bloody offering to the memory of his grandfather. But then in the fourth century, it goes wrong for the Magonids. They attack Sicily again and that's a bit of a shambles. Is that right? It's a complete shambles. And this time, it's not just that the invasion gets defeated, but that the guy who leads it, who's a guy called Himilco, so that's the great-grandson of the Hamilcar who threw himself on a funeral pyre, he commits all kinds of terrible sacrilegious acts. So he's endlessly burning down Greek temples and doing things like that. And so as a result,
我的天哪，汤姆，太残忍了。作为献给他祖父记忆的血腥祭品。但到了四世纪，马戈尼德家族的情况就不妙了。他们再次进攻西西里，结果一团糟。是这样吗？完全是一团糟。这一次，不仅入侵失败了，而且领导入侵的人——一个叫希米尔科的人，也就是那个投身火葬堆的哈米尔卡的曾孙——做出了各种可怕的亵渎行为。他不断烧毁希腊神庙，做各种类似的事情。因此，结果是，
as the Greeks see it, and indeed perhaps the Carthaginians, his army gets kind of ravaged by an epidemic. They're camped out in front of Syracuse trying to capture the city and plague just sweeps the Carthaginian camp. And Himilco kind of goes mad and he flees the siege. He goes back to Carthage. when he gets there he's so ashamed that he takes off all his finery he puts on the rough tunic of a slave he covers his hair in ashes and he kind of roams around lamenting his utter failure in front of syracuse the fact that he's abandoned his troops that he's betrayed them and then he walls himself up in his own house and kills himself okay and so obviously you know this isn't good branding for his dynasty. No.
正如希腊人所见，甚至可能是迦太基人所见，他的军队被一场瘟疫蹂躏了。他们驻扎在叙拉古城外试图占领这座城市，瘟疫席卷了迦太基军营。希米尔科有点疯了，他逃离了围城。他回到了迦太基。当他到达那里时，他感到非常羞愧，脱掉了所有的华服，穿上了奴隶的粗布长袍，在头发上撒上灰烬，四处游荡，哀叹他在叙拉古的彻底失败，哀叹他抛弃了军队，背叛了他们，然后他把自己关在房子里自杀了。好吧，显然，你知道，这对他的王朝来说不是什么好名声。不。
And it's at the end of the Magnates. Oh, my word. Yeah, pretty much. Yeah. Terrible way to end. With that story, you have the sense that perhaps something is not entirely being told. Yeah. It seems quite odd.
这是马戈尼德家族的终结。我的天哪。是的，差不多。是的。以这种方式结束真是太可怕了。听了这个故事，你会觉得也许有些事情并没有完全说出来。是的。这看起来很奇怪。
Yeah. Having listened to all this, so the way that the Carthaginians are behaving strikes me as absolutely standard kind of Mediterranean. It is. Great power politics. For all that the Greeks try to paint them as like these weird, sinister, you know, depraved, even the way their constitution works, I mean, it's not so outlandish. It's not as weird and orientalist as we would think, right?
是的。听了这一切，迦太基人的行为方式在我看来完全是地中海式的标准做法。确实如此。尽管希腊人试图把他们描绘成那种怪异、阴险、堕落的形象，甚至连他们的宪法运作方式也是如此，但我的意思是，这并不那么离奇。它并不像我们想象的那样怪异和东方主义，对吧？
I mean, this is pretty standard. Right. And so this is why Aristotle is able to praise it, is able to compare it to Crete or to Sparta. And Aristotle is praising Carthage for resisting kind of tyranny as he would praise a Greek city. And actually the backdrop to Aristotle writing about this is a demonstration of the Carthaginian refusal to accept tyranny so in the wake of the collapse of maganid power there's another guy who emerges and he inevitably is called hanno yes but of course as i say waves of hanno's yeah so he comes to be called hanno the great and it's honestly like a kind of football league where year after year syracuse and carthage
我的意思是，这很标准。没错。这就是为什么亚里士多德能够赞美它，能够将其与克里特或斯巴达相提并论。亚里士多德赞美迦太基抵制暴政，就像他赞美希腊城市一样。实际上，亚里士多德写这篇文章的背景是迦太基拒绝接受暴政的证明。因此，在马戈尼德权力崩溃之后，又出现了另一个人，他不可避免地被称为汉诺。是的，但正如我所说，一波又一波的汉诺。是的，他后来被称为“大汉诺”。这真的就像一个足球联赛，年复一年，叙拉古和迦太基
are meeting up and sometimes Carthage wins and sometimes Syracuse wins. But basically they're kind of, you know, they're top of the league. You know, sometimes, you know, one is at the top, sometimes the other is at the top. The middle of the fourth century. So this is when Aristotle is very much hanging around in Greece. Hanno the Great wins this crushing naval victory over Syracuse. And this kind of redounds tremendously to his glory. He's incredibly rich. It enables him to rule in Syracuse as the dominant figure for about two decades. But as the time passes, the Carthaginians become ever more restive and they fear that Hanno is kind of aiming at, I suppose, what we today would call anachronistically
相遇，有时迦太基赢，有时叙拉古赢。但基本上，你知道，他们是联赛顶尖的。你知道，有时一个在顶端，有时另一个在顶端。四世纪中叶。所以这是亚里士多德在希腊的时候。大汉诺在对叙拉古的海战中取得了压倒性的胜利。这极大地增加了他的荣耀。他极其富有。这使他能够作为主导人物在叙拉古统治了大约二十年。但随着时间的推移，迦太基人变得越来越不安，他们担心汉诺的目标是，我想，我们今天会不合时宜地称之为
a dictatorship. Perhaps the Greeks would call it tyranny. And so Hanno, it is said, is aware that there are conspiracies against him among his peers in the Carthaginian elite. And so he invites them all to a banquet to celebrate the wedding of his daughter. And the plan is that he's going to poison them. So the wine comes out, he's waiting for all his guests to kind of keel over dead. But he gets rumbled. We're not told how. Maybe there's a kind of, you know, a taster or someone keels over. But anyway, his attempt to poison the elite fails.
独裁。也许希腊人会称之为暴政。所以据说汉诺意识到迦太基精英阶层中的同僚对他有阴谋。于是他邀请他们所有人参加他女儿的婚礼宴会。计划是他要毒死他们。酒端上来了，他等着所有的客人都倒地身亡。但他被发现了。我们不知道是怎么发现的。也许有一个试毒员，或者有人倒下了。但无论如何，他毒害精英的企图失败了。
And so on the back of this, it is said that Hanno decides that he's openly going to launch a coup against the constitution. So he frees 20,000 slaves. He recruits the local Libbyan tribes but he gets defeated he gets captured and he gets crucified and we should say that there is quite a lot of crucifixion in carthaginian history okay and the carthaginians have a habit of i mean basically if you you know you get appointed to a command and you screw it up you'll be crucified the likelihood is that you will be crucified.
因此，据说汉诺决定公开对宪法发动政变。他释放了2万名奴隶。他招募了当地的利比亚部落，但他被击败了，被俘虏并被钉死在十字架上。我们应该说，迦太基历史上有很多钉死在十字架上的刑罚。好吧，迦太基人有一个习惯，我的意思是，基本上如果你被任命为指挥官却搞砸了，你就会被钉死在十字架上。很有可能你会受到这种惩罚。
And so this is one of the things that the Romans attribute to the Carthaginians is the invention of crucifixion. And although, of course, the Romans are great, they love a bit of crucifixion themselves. They say this is a marker of how cruel the Carthaginians were. So a general is watching a battle and he says, oh God, I'm going to be absolutely crucified for this. Yeah, literally.
所以这是罗马人归咎于迦太基人的事情之一，即发明了钉十字架。虽然当然，罗马人也很伟大，他们自己也喜欢钉十字架。他们说这是迦太基人多么残忍的标志。所以一位将军在观看战斗时说：“哦天哪，我绝对会因为这个被钉死在十字架上。”是的，字面意思。
Literally, yeah. Literally. But again, it's this, you know, the football manager who's failed. Exactly, exactly. Up on a cross. Yeah. Tortured to death.
字面意思，是的。字面意思，是的。但同样，这就像那个失败的足球教练。完全正确，完全正确。被钉在十字架上。是的。被折磨致死。
So going back to Aristotle, he thinks, brilliant, Carthage resisted tyranny, all this kind of thing. But like all these places, Tom, this is still a place that is defined by wealth, by breeding, by this kind of patrician elite
所以回到亚里士多德，他认为，太棒了，迦太基抵制了暴政，诸如此类。但像所有这些地方一样，汤姆，这仍然是一个由财富、血统、这种贵族精英所定义的地方，
who basically control the levers of power. And by Phoenician inheritance. And that's actually what Aristotle admires. I mean, Aristotle was a tremendous snob. He thinks that people with wealth and breeding should be in a position of power. So it's like Boston, 19th century Boston, Tom. I think it's even more like Venice. And there's a wonderful description of how the Carthaginian aristocracy functioned by a French historian called Gilbert Charles Piccard. And he writes, an aristocratic republic, a sort of ancient Venice, secret and well-ordered, where individuals are subject to the harsh laws of the austere and disciplined rich. So just as in Venice, you know, you have the doge, but you also have, you know, these councils that meet in sinister conclave. So in Carthage, you have the Council of the Elders, as it's called. So that's
他们基本上控制着权力的杠杆。以及腓尼基的遗产。而这正是亚里士多德所钦佩的。我的意思是，亚里士多德是一个极其势利的人。他认为有财富和血统的人应该处于权力地位。所以这就像波士顿，19世纪的波士顿，汤姆。我认为它更像威尼斯。法国历史学家吉尔伯特·查尔斯·皮卡德对迦太基贵族如何运作有精彩的描述。他写道：“一个贵族共和国，一种古老的威尼斯，秘密且秩序井然，个人受制于严苛、纪律严明的富人的严酷法律。”所以就像在威尼斯，你知道，你有总督，但你也有在阴险的秘密会议中开会的委员会。所以，在迦太基，你有所谓的长老会。所以那
literally a senate. I mean, that's what a senate means, you know, assembly of elders. And you have this mysterious body of men called the Tribunal of 104. These are the guys who appoint the generals, who appoint the officials, who supervise the law courts, who set up panels of commissioners to investigate things that go wrong. So these are the people who would sentence an incompetent general to crucifixion. But equally, of course, if they turn out to be incompetent, then the same fate may be visited on them. Then they could be crucified. Absolutely. And you have two senior magistrates called sufets know it's kind of analogous to the the hebrew word for judge and these are they're kind of like consuls yeah so the romans have consuls they are magistrates
字面意思就是参议院。我的意思是，这就是参议院的意思，你知道，长老会议。你还有这个神秘的机构，被称为104人法庭。这些人任命将军，任命官员，监督法庭，设立调查委员会来调查出错的事情。所以这些人会判处无能的将军死刑。但同样，如果他们自己变得无能，那么同样的命运也可能降临到他们身上。他们也可能被钉死在十字架上。绝对的。你还有两名高级行政官，被称为“苏菲特”，你知道，这有点类似于希伯来语中的“法官”，他们有点像执政官。是的，所以罗马人有执政官，他们是行政官，
who are elected in pairs and they serve a term of office for one year and there's a popular assembly as well there is also a popular assembly so there is also a kind of democratic element as well so it's kind of complicated system that does nevertheless seem to work. And I think the reason for that is that, you know, it is above all a city of merchants and everyone in Carthage recognises that the wealth and the power of Carthage is founded in its commercial aptitudes. And so people at the head of the state recognise what the goals of Carthaginian policy have to be. I mean, Carthage has to kind of keep markets open. It has to open
成对选举产生，任期一年。还有一个公民大会。也有一个公民大会。所以也有某种民主因素。所以这是一个复杂的系统，但它似乎确实有效。我认为原因在于，你知道，它首先是一个商人城市，迦太基的每个人都认识到迦太基的财富和权力建立在商业天赋之上。所以国家领导人认识到迦太基的政策目标必须是什么。我的意思是，迦太基必须保持市场开放。它必须通过
up new markets, whether that is by, you know, at the point of a sword or by kind of imposing trade treaties on kind of distant parts to monopolise the exploitation of these various territories. If you can't have a monopoly, then you establish pacts that will determine how much things should be sold for, to ensure the freedom of the seas, to abolish piracy, to cut down rival powers, all these kinds of things. These are the constants of Carthaginian policy throughout its history. But by the fourth century, I think you are starting to see a kind of move from that kind of Venetian Portuguese policy of imperialism. To a more Spanish approach. Or dare one say a Roman one. So those Venetian settlements in the west of Sicily, so Pernomus
剑尖，或者通过对遥远地区强加贸易条约来垄断这些地区的开发，从而开辟新市场。如果你不能垄断，那么你就建立契约来决定商品价格，以确保海洋自由，废除海盗，削弱竞争对手，所有这些事情。这些是迦太基历史上政策的常数。但到了四世纪，我认为你开始看到从那种威尼斯-葡萄牙式的帝国主义政策向更西班牙式的方法转变。或者敢说，罗马式的方法。所以那些西西里西部的威尼斯定居点，比如帕诺姆斯
and Mocia, for instance, by the fourth century, they have basically been absorbed into a Carthaginian empire. And at the same time, Carthage is also planting colonies in Sicily of its own directly to maintain its control. Because of course, you've got Carthage on the African side of that strait, and you've got Sicily, the western side of Sicily. Carthage absolutely needs to control those seas because without it, you know, its trade will be throttled. So the major city that it founds in this period is what's now Marsala, as in the wine, Nelson's favourite wine, but was known by the Romans as Lilibaeum. And this is founded in 397 after the Syracusans had captured and obliterated Mochia, the foul-smelling
和莫西亚，到四世纪，它们基本上已经被吸收到迦太基帝国中了。与此同时，迦太基也在西西里岛直接建立自己的殖民地以维持控制。因为当然，你在海峡的非洲一侧有迦太基，在西西里岛的西侧有西西里。迦太基绝对需要控制这些海域，因为没有它，你知道，它的贸易就会被扼杀。所以它在这个时期建立的主要城市是现在的马尔萨拉，就像那种酒，纳尔逊最喜欢的酒，但罗马人称之为利利巴厄姆。这是在公元前397年，叙拉古人占领并夷平了莫西亚——那个岛上散发着恶臭的
city on the island with its garum factory. And Lilibaeum is founded to be a kind of, you know, a sanctuary for people who had fled Mochia. But also it's settled by lots and lots of Carthaginian colonists. And it's basically the westernmost point of Sicily. And it has massive walls, so kind of Sicily. And it has massive walls, so kind of 20 feet, has a great big ditch. It's built to be completely impregnable. And this idea of a Carthaginian empire that is simultaneously Phoenician, I think is exemplified by the fact
鱼露工厂的城市——之后建立的。利利巴厄姆的建立是为了成为逃离莫西亚的人的避难所。但它也由大量的迦太基殖民者定居。它基本上是西西里岛的最西端。它有巨大的城墙，大约20英尺高，有一条大沟。它被建成完全坚不可摧的样子。而这种既是迦太基帝国又是腓尼基帝国的观念，我认为体现在这样一个事实中：
that this is the point when the Carthaginians introduced their coinage with the palm tree on it. And the Greek word for palm tree is phoenix. And so there's an illusion there to the point when the carthaginians introduce their coinage with the palm tree on it and the greek word for palm tree is phoenix and so there's a kind of allusion there to the idea of the phoenicians so they're still even at this late stage very much into the kind of phoenician heritage they are because it provides a way of allowing what had previously been independent phoenician settlements to feel that they have a kind of stake in what effectively is becoming a Carthaginian empire. And if they capture Greek cities, so they capture Salinas, for instance, on the south coast, it had always been a kind of thorn in the Carthaginian side. They capture that and they plant a Phoenician garrison on the Acropolis and other Greek cities are made tributary. So that basically in this
这是迦太基人引入带有棕榈树图案的硬币的时候。棕榈树的希腊语是“phoenix”。所以这里有一种暗示，即迦太基人引入带有棕榈树图案的硬币，而棕榈树的希腊语是“phoenix”，所以这里有一种对腓尼基人观念的暗示。所以即使在这么晚的阶段，他们仍然非常看重腓尼基遗产。他们确实如此，因为它提供了一种方式，让以前独立的腓尼基定居点感到它们在实际上正在成为迦太基帝国的东西中拥有某种利益。如果他们占领了希腊城市，比如南海岸的塞利努斯，它一直是迦太基的一根刺。他们占领了它，并在卫城上安置了腓尼基驻军，其他希腊城市也被迫纳贡。所以基本上在这个
period, the fact that Carthage rules the western half of Sicily is being established by treaties that are being signed with Syracuse and with other Greek cities in the east. And so we're now into the age of Alexander the Great. And so I think that by this point Carthage is kind of becoming an empire in a way that would be recognisable, say, to Alexander. Yes, so Tom, Alexander obviously never did conquer Carthage, but he was said to have thought about it. And presumably that reflects a wider ambition among sort of Greek warlords, as it were. They think, you know, let's bring Carthage down. Carthage is a prize worth taking.
时期，迦太基统治西西里岛西部的事实是通过与叙拉古及东部其他希腊城市签署的条约确立的。所以我们现在进入了亚历山大大帝时代。所以我认为到这一点，迦太基正在以一种亚历山大可能会认可的方式成为一个帝国。是的，汤姆，亚历山大显然从未征服过迦太基，但据说他考虑过。这大概反映了希腊军阀中更广泛的野心。他们想，你知道，让我们打倒迦太基。迦太基是一个值得夺取的奖品。
Well, I mean, I think obviously what Alexander's example does is give to other Greeks the notion that going off and conquering great empires, you know, what a tremendous thing to do. And Carthage is a kind of obvious one. And so say in Syracuse, you know, as we've said, the Syracusans are endlessly going to war with Carthage, but there is this sense that it's kind of like a sport where, you know, it's governed by rules. Neither one is trying to knock the other one out. But in the wake of Alexander and his successes, you have this guy called Agathocles, who's actually a very humble stock. He's a kind of a son of a potter, but he rises to become the tyrant of Syracuse. And he actually ends up invading Africa.
嗯，我的意思是，我认为亚历山大的榜样显然给了其他希腊人一种观念，即去征服伟大的帝国，你知道，这是一件多么了不起的事情。而迦太基是一个显而易见的例子。所以，比如在叙拉古，正如我们所说，叙拉古人不断地与迦太基开战，但有一种感觉，这就像一种运动，你知道，它受规则支配。双方都没有试图彻底击败对方。但在亚历山大及其成功之后，出现了一个叫阿加托克利斯的人，他出身非常卑微。他是一个陶工的儿子，但他崛起成为了叙拉古的僭主。他实际上最终入侵了非洲。
I mean, this is the first time that a Greek army has landed in Africa. And at one point, it looks as though Carthage is going to fall to Agathocles. And if that had happened, then obviously that would have been a feat comparable to Alexander overthrowing Persia. by this invasion that they immolate 500 of the children of the Carthaginian elite. In desperation. In desperation. In the event it all goes wrong, there's a kind of uprising back in Syracuse and Agathocles has to go back home, Scarpa's back. And the Carthaginians sign a treaty with Agathocles, which is, I mean, it's pretty tough on them. They have to pay a large indemnity, but they survive. And within a few decades, they are back as prosperous, as intimidating as ever. And so Carthage has survived where Persia didn't. Carthage has held off the Greek adventurer trying to overthrow it. And I think that that's tribute to the fact that it's just a very, very formidable power. I mean,
我的意思是，这是希腊军队第一次在非洲登陆。有那么一刻，看起来迦太基要被阿加托克利斯攻陷了。如果发生了这种情况，那显然将是一项堪比亚历山大推翻波斯的壮举。在这次入侵中，他们绝望地将迦太基精英的500名孩子投入火中。在绝望中。在绝望中。最终一切都搞砸了，叙拉古发生了起义，阿加托克利斯不得不回家。迦太基人与阿加托克利斯签署了一项条约，我的意思是，这对他们来说相当苛刻。他们必须支付巨额赔偿，但他们幸存了下来。几十年内，他们又恢复了往日的繁荣和威慑力。所以迦太基在波斯失败的地方幸存了下来。迦太基抵挡住了试图推翻它的希腊冒险家。我认为这归功于它是一个非常、非常强大的力量。我的意思是，
probably we arrive at the dawning of the third century BC. It's clearly the most formidable power in the Western Mediterranean. The comparison that we mentioned in the last episode, we talked about how after the French Revolution, during the French Revolution and the Napoleonic Wars, the French would say, well, we are the land power, we are Rome, and Britain is Carthage, you know, sort of only interested in money and navies. Is Carthage still similar? So you said that Carthage was becoming more of a kind of land empire with bases and forts and stuff like that. But is it still very, very reliant on its navy rather than its army? Well, I mean, to pursue the comparison with
我们可能到达了公元前三世纪的黎明。它显然是西地中海最强大的力量。我们在上一集提到的比较，我们谈到法国大革命后，在法国大革命和拿破仑战争期间，法国人会说，嗯，我们是陆权国家，我们是罗马，而英国是迦太基，你知道，只对金钱和海军感兴趣。迦太基仍然相似吗？所以你说迦太基正变得更像一个拥有基地和堡垒之类的陆地帝国。但它是否仍然非常、非常依赖海军而不是陆军？嗯，我的意思是，为了继续与
Britain, of course, I mean, the British are not averse to conquering territory, but they are tending to do it because they need naval bases and then to maintain their naval bases, they need to control the hinterland and they need to keep the French out or whatever. And I think it's rather similar to that. The Carthaginians are not necessarily interested in territory for its own sake, but they are interested absolutely in maintaining their control of Western Sicily because otherwise they'll lose control of the Straits. They want to keep control of Sardinia. They want to keep control of Southern Spain because without that, they won't be able to maintain the source of their wealth, which is trade. But that is why the French do compare
英国进行比较，我的意思是，英国人并不反对征服领土，但他们倾向于这样做是因为他们需要海军基地，然后为了维持他们的海军基地，他们需要控制腹地，他们需要把法国人挡在外面等等。我认为这与此相当相似。迦太基人并不一定对领土本身感兴趣，但他们绝对有兴趣维持对西西里西部的控制，否则他们将失去对海峡的控制。他们想保持对撒丁岛的控制。他们想保持对西班牙南部的控制，因为没有这些，他们将无法维持财富的来源，即贸易。但这就是为什么法国人会比较
Britain in the Napoleonic Wars to Carthage. And actually the weird thing is that all the places that you've mentioned, they're the sort of places, I mean, you said about Nelson liking that wine, they're the places that he's always visiting. Absolutely. For the same reason. So the Carthaginians are interested in the same harbours that the British were interested in in the 18th century. Yeah.
拿破仑战争中的英国与迦太基。而且奇怪的是，你提到的所有地方，都是那种地方，我的意思是，你提到纳尔逊喜欢那种酒，它们都是他经常访问的地方。绝对的。原因相同。所以迦太基人对18世纪英国人感兴趣的港口感兴趣。是的。
Because if you want a blue water empire, you have to have a bit of territorial control. I mean, by this point i realized that we haven't actually described what carthage looks like in its its heyday it is a very very impressive city because it's a very wealthy city so you've still got you know the beer service acropolis which is the kind of the old town the old city is counterpointed by a kind of grid system yeah that's kind of cutting edge design, the same kind that you have in Alexandria. And if you imagine kind of the Acropolis, the Bersa, and slopes running down to the sea,
因为如果你想要一个蓝水帝国，你就必须拥有一定的领土控制权。我的意思是，到这一点，我意识到我们还没有真正描述迦太基在鼎盛时期的样子。它是一个非常、非常令人印象深刻的城市，因为它是一个非常富有的城市。所以你仍然有，你知道，比尔萨卫城，那是旧城区，旧城市与一种网格系统相呼应，是的，那是某种尖端设计，和你在亚历山大港拥有的那种一样。如果你想象一下卫城，比尔萨，以及向下延伸到大海的斜坡，
the streets look like a kind of fan running down to the shoreline. Further from the old centre of the city, you have kind of beautiful villas. You have docks. You have harbours. You have massive arsenals. You have teeming industrial zones yeah you have the tophet of course you have cemeteries temples beautiful temples yes particularly to baal hamon the great patron and tanit his partner these are the great patrons of carthage but you also have massive bristling walls and these extend more than 18 miles around
街道看起来像一把扇子延伸到海岸线。远离城市旧中心的地方，你有美丽的别墅。你有码头。你有港口。你有巨大的军火库。你有熙熙攘攘的工业区，是的，你当然有托菲特，你有墓地，神庙，美丽的神庙，是的，特别是献给伟大的赞助人巴力哈蒙和他的伴侣塔尼特，这些是迦太基的伟大赞助人，但你也有巨大的、布满尖刺的城墙，这些城墙延伸超过18英里，环绕着
the limits of the city. And these are what had seen Agathocles off. He just, you know, he couldn't break through. And you'd look at Carthage at the beginning of the third century BC and you'd say, you know, she is absolutely secure. No one can possibly rival her. Her only conceivable rival Syracuse has had a crack and has dismally failed you know she's going to last forever i mean who can rival her but tom on our rides and thinking a new rival will emerge from the backwater of italy central italy and that that will set the stage for the most extraordinary superpower clash in ancient history. Is that about right?
城市的边界。而这些就是击退阿加托克利斯的东西。他只是，你知道，他无法突破。你在公元前三世纪初看着迦太基，你会说，你知道，她绝对是安全的。没有人能与她抗衡。她唯一可能的竞争对手叙拉古已经尝试过并惨败了，你知道她会永远存在，我的意思是，谁能与她抗衡？但汤姆，我们正在思考一个新的竞争对手将从意大利的后方，意大利中部崛起，这将为古代历史上最非凡的超级大国冲突奠定舞台。是这样吗？
Well, we'll find out in our next episode when we will be looking at the rise of Rome. Crikey, what drama. So listen, if you are a member of our own sinister and decadent mercantile empire, the Rest is History Club, as you probably know, you can listen to those episodes about the battle between Carthage and Rome. You can listen to that right now. If you're not, if you're very much on the outside looking in,
嗯，我们将在下一集中找到答案，届时我们将审视罗马的崛起。天哪，多么戏剧性。所以听着，如果你是我们自己阴险而颓废的商业帝国“历史就是一切”俱乐部的成员，正如你可能知道的那样，你可以收听那些关于迦太基和罗马之间战斗的剧集。你现在就可以收听。如果你不是，如果你是一个彻头彻尾的局外人，
then I'm afraid you'll just have to wait until, as the young people say, that episode drops. So yeah, you can either be part of the elite or you can be part of the rabble. Your choice. But either way, it's Carthage versus Rome next.
那么恐怕你只能等到，正如年轻人所说，那一集发布了。所以是的，你可以成为精英的一部分，也可以成为暴民的一部分。你的选择。但无论如何，接下来是迦太基对阵罗马。
Don't miss it. Live and exclusive on the rest is history bye-bye bye-bye i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
不要错过。在“历史就是一切”中直播且独家播出，再见，再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持“娱乐就是一切”。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和现场门票的优先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。